Você sabia que uma ferretina abaixo de
70, que a maioria dos laboratórios acha
normal, pode ser a sentença definitiva
pro seu cabelo continuar caindo? Não
importa quantos shampoos caros você use.
Estudos recentes de dermatologia
investigativa mostram que para o cabelo
parar de cair e voltar a crescer, você
precisa de níveis de estoque de ferro
muito acima do mínimo aceitável para
apenas não ter anemia. Se você está
vendo tufos no ralo e acha que a sua
estresse pare, agora eu vou te mostrar
os três alvos nutricionais exatos que eu
busco nos exames da minha clínica para
reverter a queda capilar números que
ninguém te conta.
Todo dia eu atendo alguém que senta na
minha frente quase chorando, dizendo:
"Doutor, estou ficando careca e meu
outro médico disse que meus exames estão
ótimos e que é só estresse." Olha,
estresse derruba cabelo? Sim, derruba
muito o cortisol alto mata o folículo,
mas na grande maioria das vezes o buraco
é mais embaixo. O corpo humano é uma
máquina de sobrevivência extremamente
inteligente. Quando falta nutriente, ele
corta o suprimento do que é supérfolo
para salvar o que é vital. E adivinha
só? Cabelo pro seu corpo é luxo. Ele
prefere manter seu coração batendo, o
seu cérebro funcionando, do que te
deixar com uma cabeleira bonita. Então,
se o cabelo está caindo, é um grito de
socorro do seu metabolismo, dizendo que
a conta não está fechando. E o maior
erro que eu vejo as pessoas cometendo é
aceitar valores de referência de
laboratório que são baseados na média de
uma população geralmente doente e não na
saúde ideal. Vamos conversar com a visão
funcional agora, olho no olho. O
primeiro culpado e talvez o mais
silencioso de todos é a ferritina.
ferritina é o estoque de ferro no seu
corpo. Pensa nela como uma conta
poupança. O ferro sérico é o dinheiro na
carteira. Você pode ter dinheiro na
carteira, mas se a conta poupança tiver
zerada, qualquer imprevisto te quebra.
Nos laboratórios, se a sua ferretina der
15 ou 20, eles dizem que está normal.
Mas para o folículo capilar isso é fome.
O folículo precisa de uma ferritina
idealmente acima de 70 para manter a
fase anágena, que é a fase de
crescimento. Abaixo disso, o corpo entra
em racionamento e joga o cabelo pra fase
telógena. A fase de queda é batata. Vejo
mulheres com ferritinha de 30 tomando
remédio para calvice sem resultado
quando precisavam era de um bom bife de
fígado ou suplementação guiada. Aí
entramos no segundo ponto que é o zinco.
O zinco é como se fosse o mestre de
obras da construção do fio. Ele
participa da síntese de DNA e RNA no
folículo, que é uma das células que mais
se divide no corpo. Sem zinco, a obra
para. Só que aqui tem um pulo do gato
que pouca gente sabe. Zinco e cobre
competem pela mesma porta de entrada no
intestino. Se você sai tomando zinco
loucamente por conta própria, você pode
causar uma deficiência de cobre. Aí cria
outro problema. Na visão funcional,
buscamos um zinco plasmáticoizado,
geralmente no quartil superior da
referência, mas sempre de olho no
equilíbrio. Não é sobre tomar o pote
todo, é sobre a dose certa. E não dá
para falar de cabelo sem falar da
vitamina D de dado. Gente, vitamina D
não é vitamina, é um pré-hormônio.
Existe um receptor específico no seu
folículo capilar chamado VDR. Sem
vitamina D suficiente acoplando ali, o
ciclo do cabelo não reinicia. Sabe
aquela queda que nunca recupera o
volume? Pode ser falta de sol. Nos
exames. A referência diz que 20 ou 30 é
suficiente. Para osso, talvez. Mas para
cabelo ou pro cérebro, esquece. Na minha
prática, eu busco níveis entre 60 e 80
para otimizar essa resposta imunológica
de crescimento.
Ah, doutor, mas é biotina. Eu comprei
aquelas gominhas rosas na farmácia. Vou
ser bem sincero com você, como se a
gente tivesse tomando um café juntos
aqui. A menos que você tenha uma
deficiência genética raríssima ou coma
clara de ovo crua todo dia. Deficiência
de biotina é muito difícil acontecer. A
indústria ama vender biotina porque é
barato e o nome ficou famoso. Mas na
maioria dos casos o que falta não é a
gominha colorida, é a proteína de
verdade. Cabelo é quase 100% queratina
que é proteína. Se você vive de salada e
bolacha, água e sal, ou se entrou na
moda dessas injeções para emagrecer e
parou de comer, seu cabelo vai cair. Não
tem suplemento que corrija a falta de
tijolo para construir o muro. Então,
antes de gastar rios de dinheiro em
loções mágicas, o protocolo básico em
investigação precisa incluir ferretina,
buscando acima de 70, vitamina D de dado
entre 60 e 80, zinco e uma ingestão
proteica decente. É o básico bem feito
que funciona. O corpo não erra. Se ele
está descartando o cabelo, ele está te
avisando que falta nutrição real. Agora
saia do vídeo se você gosta superficial.
Eu preciso simplificar aqui por causa do
YouTube e das limitações regulamentares.
Na comunidade fechada não tem esse
filtro. Lá eu compartilho protocolos
completos, combinações precisas,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames e casos clínicos que
não posso mostrar aqui. É acesso direto
ao meu cérebro médico. Gostei em lives
semanais, PDFs exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp, integração com quem está
realmente comprometido. Se você quiser
ir além, tem o nível dois, com ações
científicas de 2 horas a cada 15 dias,
desse secando artigo por artigo e
entrando nos bastidores que a indústria
não quer que você entenda. Seu nome
aparece nos vídeos, você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite.
Poucos têm essa coragem. A pergunta é:
você está entre eles?